[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue pour ce nouveau
numéro du 7-8 culture voici est le
sommaire un test adn suffit-il à se
sentir père c'est la question posée par
la pièce de théâtre l'ordre des choses
elle était à la fiche de la ferme du
manet à montigny le bretonneux dimanche
29 septembre une comédie avec notamment
pascal légitimus interview à suivre dans
cette émission
chaque année c'est un rendez vous très
attendu pour les amateurs de bd la ville
de butte accueille les 12 et 13 octobre
la 26e édition le festival de la bande
dessinée
à cette occasion des personnes
condamnées et suivie par la justice ont
pu participer à un atelier avec et rock
le créateur de la série les profs
laguiole nouveau lieu d'exposition aux
prises miles en cours accueillent
jusqu'à la fin du mois d'octobre
post 9 51 par l'artiste tas d une
exposition consacrée à l'exploration
spatiale au tour des années 50 et 60
la ferme du manet à montigny le
bretonneux accueillait dimanche la pièce
l'ordre des choses mises en scène par
richard berry un jour bernard et sa
femme juliette doit débarquer chez eux
un certain thomas qui prétend être le
fils de ce dernier problème à bernard a
toujours prétendu qu'ils étaient
infertiles à la fin de la représentation
nous avons pu rencontrer les comédiens
[Musique]
profite au chômage voilà il manquait des
points pour les assedic blacks à part
tout simplement j'ai lu à peu près à la
sans prétention aucune 18 pièces en deux
ans et il se trouve que cela cela
faisait partie des trois préférés et le
timing permettait j'avais du temps pour
l'assumer c'est la première fois que je
joue un rôle de faux culs menteur
mauvaise foi j'aimerais beaucoup de
choses notamment quel inconnu entre
autres mais justement mon frère et ma
fille me l'ont dit les patrons longtemps
me dit voir là dedans je t'ai jamais vu
là dedans effectivement c'est un
registre que je n'ai vu que j'ai
rarement assumer et ça me plait pas mal
[Musique]
ça formidable des raisons qui fait c'est
ce qui m'a énormément plu dans la pièce
de marc faye et cie que c'était
extrêmement actuelle ça me concerne et
pour le coup ben je me sens très très
bien qu'on la joue maintenant
ils ont réagi à des endroits où on
n'avait pas l'habitude mais on n'a pas
encore l'habitude mais étonnamment ils
ont ri à des moments très inattendu pour
nous en fait moi j'ai un budget fait je
paye des gens courir a des moments mais
que pour moi at il bien pouvoir
j'avais beaucoup d'argent quand tu
retires sommes tous les deux sur scène
moi j'entends jean cau l'isq qu'il ya
une envie de une écoute et puis le thème
de la pièce je pense qu'ils le
connaissent
alors on va se passer quelque chose
effectivement ça monte en puissance
[Musique]
moi j'ai un bouquin qui sort oui chez
laffont est là et foraine s'appelle
l'alphabétisation sous texte rend terme
inconnu
en fait je partis du principe que on a
inventé des mois des inconnus comme
bouleversifiant mélange il continue avec
un copain journaliste ejb rejoint dans
cette vibration et on a trop on la
refait tout l'alphabet et le principe
c'est d'enlever le maître ou le rejeter
une lettre vous faites instagram 1
on installe g tous les deux vous
surveiller tout ça sur je suis
professeur de sur le 9e art sera à
l'honneur les 12 et 13 octobre château
de buc ce sera la 26e édition du
festival de la bande dessinée dans ce
cadre pour la deuxième année consécutive
un atelier de création de bd a eu lieu
avec des personnes condamnées et suivies
par la justice ce et erroc l'auteur des
profs qui a dirigé l'opération
la bonne ambiance est au rendez vous
pour cet atelier de bande dessinée un
peu particulier les cinq participants
sont des personnes condamnées et suivi
par le service pénitentiaire d'insertion
et de probation des yvelines cette
opération a lieu dans le cadre de la 26e
édition du festival de l'udc consacré au
neuvième art but est vraiment de travail
ensemble de découvrir une activité qu'on
connaît pas forcément et puis de pouvoir
se dépasser
on s'y attend la confiance en soi le
dépassement de je connais pas mais je
peux y arriver
les participants ont eu deux jours pour
imaginer une bande dessinée comme
l'année dernière c'est le dessinateur et
rock qui l'on doit notamment la série
les profs qui a conduit cet atelier ça
dieu qu'on connaît pas c'est une type de
public qu'on connaît pas non plus parce
que notre les interventions scolaires on
va dans les écoles les médiathèques là
c'est intéressant déjà travail des
adultes ce que j'avais jamais fait moins
avant l'année dernière
ce que je trouve très que chacun
s'entraide chaque participant donne un
coup de main sur le dessin de l'autre
pour ce petit groupe placés sous main de
justice cette activité a lieu dans le
cadre d'un module de réinsertion je
dessine énormément oui j'adore le dessin
donc tout ce qui est activités manuelles
aussi j'adore ça veut elle prend son
temps pour nous expliquer verrez pas les
conseils comment on peut faire extraire
j'ai eu un prof et avec été excellents
franchement j'ai pas sans agréablement
m'avait des conseils pour le font pour
faire plus de rôles hier pour faire plus
de la distance
toutes les oeuvres vont être réunies et
seront exposés lors de la 26e édition du
festival de la bd à buc et au programme
donc pour cette 20e édition du festival
de la bd abus que des rencontres avec la
cinquantaine d'auteurs présents il y
aura également des dédicaces et des
animations pour tous les âges
à noter que la veille du festival le
vendredi 11 octobre le film valérian et
la cité des mille planète sera projeté
au théâtre des arcades de buc un film de
luc besson qui est bien sûr cirer de la
bande dessinée valérian et laureline
la projection est à partir de 20h30
cette mission est simple et rapide
agent valérian vous agirez seul je pense
qu'avec ma coéquipière entendent y
construire
vous avez quasiment 20 minutes de retard
est le temps passe vite quand on s'amuse
[Musique]
on va rester dans l'univers de la
science fiction puisque le prisme à
elancourt accueille jusqu'au 31 octobre
une exposition intitulée cosmo 51
elle est située dans le tout nouvel
espace l'alcool l'artiste tu as des as
découper des images issues de
l'encyclopédie universelle du xviiie
siècle pour en faire des tableaux
représentant des chimères cosmique
elle a mélangé st pour cette exposition
avec des fonds photographiques qui sont
issus de la recherche astronomique des
années 50 jusqu'aux années 80 à peu près
donc on a la vision scientifique du
xviiie siècle et la vision scientifique
du 20e siècle et tout ça entre en
collusion petit peu comme une météorite
dans une planète vous à créer une
nouvelle image avec des personnages très
mystérieux des personnages qui sont en
élévation en lévitation
on est vraiment dans une exposition
comme son nom l indique qu'au smic
cette réflexion sur l'espace qui nous
entourent vient compléter le conseil que
guillaume perret fera le 11 octobre à
20h30 également au prisme
ce saxophoniste a signé notamment la
bande originale de 16 levers de soleil
le documentaire qui retrace l'épopée
spatiale de thomas pesquet
makane kane sur un an
[Musique]
quelques rendez vous à noter maintenant
dans vos agendas
la paroisse catholique de montigny
voisin organise une exposition inédite
vingt tableaux de yann arthus bertrand
seront exposés ce sera du 3 au 12
octobre à l'église saint-pierre du lac à
montigny le bretonneux l'association
hélium en vallée de chevreuse organise
les 5 6 12 et 13 octobre la 15e édition
de parcours d'artiste c'est cette
manifestation donne l'opportunité
notamment public de découvrir les
oeuvres d'artistes départ entre des
plasticiens ou encore des sculpteurs et
puis le même type d'initiative
cette fois ci à carrières-sur-seine le
collectif des artistes et artisans d'art
vous invitez 12 et 13 octobre parcours
culturel
cette première édition s'appelle au fil
de la et vous propose de découvrir à
pied les sites du vieux village à
travers les ateliers d'artistes
céramique art graphique ou encore
photographie d'art on va parler de cire
que maintenant puisque le festival
international du cirque revient aux
mureaux durant deux jours le chapiteau
installé au parc du sceau tour va
accueillir les meilleurs artistes de
cirque issus des quatre coins de la
planète
acrobates clowns magiciens dompteur en
tout onze numéros seront à découvrir au
cours des quatre représentations et
c'est carrie harvey qui endossera le
costume de madame royal
on a un numéro c'est mon coup de coeur
c'est voler les médecins disent ils
viennent d'australie
en fait ils font du numéro ils sont
multi primé et je vais pas trop dire
parce que je veux pas gâcher la surprise
non plus mais on sait que c'est un
numéro de la force est exceptionnel on a
aussi des niveaux raid est aussi requins
on peut dire s'est rappelé voulons les
sly matos vient de dresde il bien connu
ils vont se retourner avec le célèbre
par les creusets également le cirque du
soleil
donc ça aussi c'est fait nos quelque
chose à voir
quelques idées de sorties à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines l'humoriste de
patrick bosso sera sur la scène de la
salle jacques brel à montigny le
bretonneux pour présenter son dernier
spectacle et il aurait également du
reggae à la merise attrape avec le
concert d'alpha blondy
de son côté le tec à plaisir accueillera
la comédie musicale chance committee qui
a d'ailleurs obtenu un molière en 2019
enfin le théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines vous propose
du 9 au 12 octobre de découvrir à la
pièce gus voici un an
je voudrais les horaires pour marseille
à nice rennes je n'ai pas compris votre
demande
je voudrais les horaires pour marseille
entre amis quoi tu veux que j'aille à un
cheval
pour aller à marseille à cheval la durée
du voyage sera de 18 jours 18 jours pour
la marseille cela mais c'est quoi ce
cheval je veux y aller a trait à une
trêve je veux y aller je ne parierai
cheval je veux aller à marseille entre
anne très tôt compris entre 2,85 n'a pas
compris maintenant entre un très bon
jour entraîner pas qu'on prenne très
vas-y sort du jeu les formes si je n'en
fais pas compris
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
jamais
anissa
[Musique]
voulez vous jouer avec mademoiselle je
suis
d'accord
ça te dirait tout francs combien je
t'aime
bus se cache sous la cote de ces humains
la nuit et leur bouffe les pieds dès
qu'ils sont endormis ils se réveillent
en hurlant et lui s'enfuit en ricanant
des ricanements un peu lugubre bus a
perdu toutes ses dents du haut d'un coup
les mêmes jours sans qu'on puisse
avancer le moindre début d'explication
et pour terminer cette information
pratique qui va certainement ravir les
parents plus besoin de chercher pendant
un désert qui gardera vos enfants
pendant que vous allez voir un spectacle
le théâtre de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
met en place un service de garderie une
fois par mois
la prise en charge des enfants débutent
à 20 heures et s'achève 30 minutes après
le spectacle vous voulez venir au
spectacle
vous avez un problème de baby sitter
vous appelez tout simplement l'accueil
du théâtre vous nous dites on aimerait
bien que vous gardiez nos enfants ce
soir là et s'il ya de la place dans un
hangar de vos enfants pendant que vous
vous assistez au spectacle les la
garderie est assurée par des
professionnels de la petite enfance donc
soyez totalement rassurer sachez que le
tarif est 2è 10 euros par enfant alors
ce service de garderie éphémère débutera
à noter le 4 octobre pour le spectacle
leïla amap cas là voilà c'est la fin de
7,8 cultura merci de l'avoir suivi on se
retrouve mardi prochain pour un nouveau
numéro
[Musique]